people that don't live here don't
understand what do you think they don't
get
border patrol is not against me being
right up on their space all right
mexican soil
oh yeah look at that door's wide open
so here's an example of what roe was
talking about you just ask them how many
months they've been at it for
they're running up and down here right
people hiding in them
wow this is surreal and see the rio
grande is not that wide here
i want to put on your camera for right
now pulling us back to the united states
you're seeing the actual thing yourself
the company has already been
paid to build that border wall how are
they paid first
you don't even see it on the road they
go under the fans to go over the fence
you know the cartel
owns property and homes on this side of
the border
what's the story rail right now we're
gonna go look for one
we've got some things set up they're
just not confirmed yet so
meanwhile we'll look for a story but the
goal is to find a rancher right we will
find a rancher
we will find around we're gonna stumble
across one and somebody's ranch okay
raul has not let us down once this trip
so i'm confident we're gonna get into a
ranch a rancher's life here and see what
he has to say
[Music]
we're headed to a park over here in
benitez
where they cut a few hundred illegal
aliens earlier not too long ago maybe
within the last 30 minutes or something
so i'm gonna try to stumble across that
[Music]
basically they got a bunch of illegal
aliens that were crossing a little while
ago maybe within the last 30 minutes
what they do they come and they'll come
here to this park here it's part of the
little city of benitez
okay usually you got families playing
here in the afternoons uh
walking and stuff like that
okay so here's what i was just told this
is a group that just came over
rivers not far away most of these people
have been at it for months
from central america as you can see it's
it's families it's it's mothers
it's children some fathers i'm sure
the uh vast majority of very good people
coming from bad
circumstances now the problem that i've
realized over the week here
talking different people is when this is
happening
you have u.s border patrol putting their
resources here
somewhere else maybe half mile mile down
there
well that's when the dark stuff happens
and that's when
you know the drugs are moving across the
dark
human trafficking that sort of stuff is
happening at this time
i think the reason why border patrol is
not against me being right up on their
space
is because there's a gag order it's not
written but it's
it's de facto nobody can talk about
anything and i think they want
the story shown because it's currently
uh well not really out there you just
ask them how many months they've been at
it for how many months
cuantos quantos
[Music]
you're seeing that you're seeing the
actual thing yourself you're seeing
these little kids
luckily there's no babies crying or
anything i said that that's
heartbreaking
i found this throne what is this
that right there if you look at it it's
uh that's an undercover unit right there
this is
it's a property bag basically they put
their property into a little bag
okay and they they take off this seal
here
and then they'll get it said like
they'll give this to the person he'll
have what if they have money in it or
whatever
they'll put their name on it so they'll
particular they'll put their property
and store it away
and they'll give them this because this
was their little receipt basically
there's a receipt number the receipt
will say you know i
i need my property back here's the bag
they'll look for the property and
they'll give them back their little bag
with all their stuff in it
transport van yeah it's an empty
transport van hit it that way to go pick
up everybody else
yeah the look in their eyes you know
just tired and fearful and
and powerless they never know what's
going to happen on their journey
like you never know what's going to
happen and that that's the screwed up
part you know what
at the end of the day something might
happen to one of these females and
their family members right there but
they don't say nothing they can't do
nothing because they're helpless also
they're they're in a helping situation
at the end of the day we all come from
somewhere in this world at some time or
another the united states is a
multi-party everybody
it all started off from somewhere else
yeah and came to this country and
moved on since then other than the
native americans right we're all
we're all immigrants i had the
discussion this next i was watching a
video where
and it's in new mexico yeah
that were protesting about people coming
across and illegals and all that stuff
well an indian guy showed up i'm
excuse the way i'm gonna work there but
an indian guy showed up and and he said
wait a minute
what are you all talking about all of
you are illegal
you all came into my country right it's
all perspective right
yes well tell me one country that
doesn't have a shitty history with a
bunch of darkness to it
doesn't discredit any of it but
look at any country in the world whether
that be turkey
russia this is the only country in the
world
that will allow what's happening to
happen
any other country though shoot you did
no no uh
a lot but like italy will we'll be doing
this too
you're right italy you know but they
didn't put countries but didn't they put
a stop to that also i don't know where
it's at right now in italy
if i'm not mistaken they put a stop to
it because
they had that problem where all of a
sudden everybody went to them and
then they're they got so much well they
don't know what to do either
i saw it last summer when i was there i
talked to a guy that came from
afghanistan he tried 11 times his buddy
got shot at the hungarian border he
finally got in
nicest guy ever he was like that guy
taught me something he said
and never give up right yeah i mean the
guy was at it for years
i agree with you i agree that there
needs to be a legal process
because we are a country of laws and the
second we lose that
then we turn into a much shitty country
what do we have once we
lose that yeah then we then we turn into
laws are said
so there's no chaos or to prevent chaos
imagine that we had no laws everybody
did whatever the hell they wanted to
you wouldn't be holding that camera
someone has taken it from you i've been
in these places it's not healthy
it's almost unbelievable but raul's
saying we're going to get on a boat
we're going to try to get on it at least
we don't have our passports but he's
saying we could probably get over with
ids
get on a boat and they're pulling five
six cars yeah
it's a ferry a ferry by hand with a rope
can you believe that i can't believe
that that's like something out of
cambodia
we're gonna you're gonna have a new
experience i'm gonna have a new
experience forever that's
every second with you it's actually a
port of entry also
okay guys the sponsor of today's video
is cuts clothing
for the last two years i've been looking
for a t-shirt that's both functional and
stylish and i finally found it this is a
t-shirt that can take a beating and keep
up with the texas heat
i've been in at the border but also be
worn out to a nice
dinner these teas are made for the long
run they don't peel the collar keeps its
shape and you can wash it a bunch of
times without any fading
it's both buttery soft and super durable
i don't iron
i never will and cuts don't wrinkle it's
a perfect match for me
on this texas shoot i wore the same
shirt for five days uh not in a row
without washing i did a quick wash in my
hotel sink at night and it was dry the
next morning
fantastic for traveling they also have
excellent hoodies
and long sleeve shirts if you want the
best t-shirt that i've come across after
years of searching
here's your chance to get one at a
discount to receive 15
off your order click on the cuts link
below in the description cuts.team
peter or use the promo code peter at
checkout
i wouldn't recommend something to you
that i didn't fully believe in
or use myself if you want quality and
style without the bs
give cuts a try so what do you think
with these people living here do
some of them are probably stash houses
right they're taking
the migrants in some of them is it fair
well maybe the
abandoned buildings or the abandoned
houses they're probably being used in
stash houses
or holding points or there's people
hiding there maybe not a stash house but
like this one over here
there's people hiding in them and stuff
because you got broken windows where
people
go in and yeah what what's what's up
with this town what happened
look at that door's wide open so here's
an example what role was talking about a
lot of abandoned houses
and well migrants can go and hide
so you can see the grass that's trampled
down and stuff
so you can tell people people have
walked through here or something's gone
through there
enough to crash down the grass right but
so with the amount of flow you can
easily see how someone can be cruising
like this
and pick up whomever yes right yep
oh look at this
that's great roll i'm gonna
i'm gonna just check this really quickly
okay
i don't know i guess this must have been
an old border stop here
sort of a tourist zone snow cones ice
cream hats caps t-shirts
and then a bar over here one of the very
beautiful things about america is
it's or the united states is that it's
so mixed up it's almost like
especially these days with the way
different states have uh
taken a covet and other issues feels
like almost going to different countries
within the same country
duty-free is closed the little town has
been here forever so
okay well my career might not be here
anymore let me ask
yeah it doesn't look like a fairy rubble
yeah i haven't been here a while either
so
they don't have a theory anymore okay
how do you get to it walk through there
okay there's the ferry with the rope
yeah
i told you it exists i haven't been here
that's why all right
what's this here that's where you pay
for the theory
pedestrians cost two dollars bicycles
two motorcycles three cars pickups five
very good prices to get across
thank you take care
what a business nice to meet you where
you come from
california okay my name is tommy garcia
the captain
and the business manager all right guys
i love border crossings in the world
because
you get sometimes funky situations like
this that you could never imagine
the only you're saying the only hand
pulled
ferry in the world that connects two
countries yeah
we divide connect to countries
without international breeds it's a
ferry
yeah who owns the ferry okay that's
confidential
okay
all right guys great border crossing
camera down right oh you can have it on
i got a little longer
yeah okay every border is different a
couple summers ago i was in
kyrgyzstan to kazakhstan and the border
guy let me just
roll the camera the whole time and then
other times like getting into china that
camera better be off
are you gonna have problems okay so
here's
no traffic wow this is surreal
rebel okay it ramps down with no
passports
all right
god you know south texas is uh
is another world i like it they're
getting here
okay they're getting here and there we
see it they're going
they're pulling on the rope you can see
the rio grande is not that wide here
pretty strong current
[Applause]
when's the last time you did this raul
i've never been on it
no here we go hola
turn your engine off what's what are
your what are your thoughts of this
place for all
well they said the other side is bad but
never been there
all right coming up on mexico here
mexico we're in let's go that way
we'll come back
all right mexican soil no passport and
withdrawal anything's possible i've come
to conclude that anything can happen
with you
this city of mexico is supposedly
another hot spot
like i said i've never been to it but
hot spot as in what uh
drug cartel violence or whatever i want
to put on your camera for right now but
did that just happen
yes there's another canadian border
canadian board is completely different
okay guys we just walked
right through no identification no stop
just away from the guards
how is that possible raul well you just
usually come into the mexico border
there is there's if you only get checked
on the custom side in america
basically he's making you uh a raspberry
natural lemon or lemon juice or
oh you just said just ice lemon see this
ice and lime
see what they want oh some spice okay
see every time i've been to mexico i've
run into the nicest people
i've only been twice but i've met the
coolest people in this country
so different world cola
it just has stuff stored in there
we started looking for a rancher today
that was the the start of the mission
you want a mexican roger you want an
american
we started looking for a rancher that
was going to be the story
then you saw the story we saw on the
road
it's going to stop right here now we're
in mexico
didn't expect this and i'm not going to
expect i'm not going to guess where
we're going
right where this is leading to basically
where i guess we're going to go back
because
there ain't no using one that way i
don't know how far the city is let's
walk down
you want to take a ride and uh get some
tacos or something
how the hell will we get a ride how are
you gonna trust anyone to bring me
yeah no that's why i drive my vehicle to
mexico
that's the united states over there
peter's coming from mexico he's on a
ferry pulling us back to the united
states
bro i think you got a future in this in
youtube videos
no i'm out
back to escort
[Music]
why are you huffing and puffing i was
just pulling that thing across man
come on you got it you got six other
people helping you
that's tiring work all day long back and
forth imagine for the
the money that they're making what do
you think they're making
well you just paid them four dollars for
both of us
so imagine you saw the prices on the
cars and stuff
yeah different experience
nice guy though nice guy but much more
official much different facility
they're inside there there are a lot of
posters for sex trafficking
human slavery did you see those
women on the posters gracias
i told you that i'm like a politician
i'll shake hands with everybody i'll
talk to everybody
and i people think i'm an apple i think
people think i'm always mad because i
look mad i don't smile for pictures
but if they really get to know me oh
yeah i'm a great you're a teddy bear
but you know you know everyone i try to
at the end of the day you never know
like this guy might see me throwing on
the side of the road and
hey that's cruz becca what
how do you do do you judge anyone for
what they're doing no i don't judge
anybody for anything
yeah i'm nobody to judge homie he could
judge and at the end he'll decide
whether where you go
yeah i'm just the type of person i said
i'll say hello to everybody i'll shake
everybody's hands
at the end of the day i'll help out
everybody i can and we just take it from
there
yeah i get that vibe in south texas
there's a lot of people like you guys
are connected here community you have
good communities
trying to take care of each other
[Music]
oh wow you don't you don't even see it
from the road okay
so this is the wall oh no actually well
yeah
you can't call this a wall
what's that 35 feet there's a river
curves if you look at the water over
there
yeah on the right side is uh mexico on
the left side of the united states yep
but you look over here in front of us
the mexico is actually over here in
front of us
on the other side of the that uh brush
yeah would be the river on that side
over there there are a lot of crossings
yes into mexico yep and one's a little
more modern than what we just went
across
[Music]
we're going to go into ratama village
what were you saying rebel
you knew some people in here that were
having there's some people the other day
that uh
that came out talking to us and stuff
that
they have a problem with illegal idiots
coming into their property at night they
go under the fence they go over the
fence
nice rvs what are these they're rvs with
little houses what what
looking like storage rooms and stuff
so it's not necessarily a ranch
but uh we ended up here this is where
i guess a lot of migrants have been
coming over because the river is very
close
and i guess there's a field behind these
trees
and then they've been coming into
private residences land
it's been pretty prevalent here in this
neighborhood you know they run through
the neighborhood because the border is
only
a mile that way yeah you know it's right
over there yeah what i said when we
spoke to him that he told us and showed
us the videotapes and stuff uh
other people coming across coming under
the fence over the fence cars parking
over here
they run to the cars at night at eight
o'clock at night at three in the morning
yeah stuff like that can you can you
show us is that all right yeah yeah
what's your name what's up randy randy
peter okay so randy what's the story
the border is a mile and a half this way
okay you can see if you look real close
you can see where
right uh through the trees this wall was
has just stopped but my understanding is
they're going to try and
and start that back up again and build
it again they are
start that back up that's my
understanding so what's been going on
here
well you'll see them come and they'll
just come
running across this field okay and they
come up to this barbed wire fence right
there
okay right right on the other side of
the trees here right and try to get your
attention
and for whatever reason i don't i don't
know why
but i had a couple of them a few nights
ago trying to get my attention and
they're speaking spanish and i don't i
don't speak spanish so
you know i sit and enjoy the evening at
night because it's real quiet out here
and nice and
and they're they're running up and down
here
running up right down here right through
this through fairway okay
so so how do you how do you feel as
someone that lives here what's your
what's your feeling or take on this
i mean i'm i am thrilled that the border
patrol is out there and
they're doing their job and they're
they're trying to take care of this
problem
i it's just a tragedy it's so sad that
you know our country is going through
this right now and that we're allowing
this
you know to happen right and it's such a
humanitarian
crisis yeah that our government just is
not recognizing
people that don't live here don't
understand they just don't understand
what do you what do you think they don't
get i don't think they understand
it's not so much the the it's the fact
that these people are
are i mean they're looking some of them
are coming here looking for a better
life
yeah but what makes people here and this
isn't a a retirement community
55 and older and people are here are
genuinely concerned about their safety
and so you know we've got the border
patrol and the police on speed dial
and they're genuinely concerned about
you know their welfare and their safety
property values my understanding is that
you know the cartel owns
you know property and homes on this side
of the border
so you've seen last few months because
the policy change is a big inflow i mean
you can see by the numbers
obviously it's very obvious oh yeah it's
it's when you
when you see them they'll walk through
there and it's mostly at night
yeah and they'll just be wandering down
the street down the street here
yeah and so our people are say um
traffickers on the other side with cars
parked waiting to take them off yeah and
you mentioned that
what another big concern they have is
that
a lot of these people understand this
layout and to where if they can get
across that fence there
and get over into this community
especially at night can we walk over
there sure
especially at night right then
they've got um they'll have the
whoever's picking them up the cartel or
whoever is just they'll drive out here
and they'll come out and jump in the car
and drive off
right yeah so it's a tough situation
yeah yeah it is really tough and i i
mean my heart just breaks for these
people
and the children that are still in that
detention center down in
donations right it's just so tragic yeah
tragic
what we're doing to these this you know
it's messy the longer i'm here the more
difficult and confusing it gets to be
honest yeah i mean not confusing is the
far
since we have a problem there's a big
problem yeah it's huge um
that needs to be addressed yeah it
doesn't seem like this is sustainable i
don't feel like this is sustainable how
it's currently going
no no and and to be honest
texans people that live here god bless
them they're fed up they're putting
their we're not they're not putting up
with it
yeah people are gonna put their foot
down i think so much of the country i
grew up in vermont
they just have no understanding what the
borders like i have no understanding
until a week ago i had no understanding
of what the borders like
what do you have to say to people in
other parts of the country that
you know it's a big hot topic it's a
tough topic what would you have to say
to people that aren't living here
who people that don't understand um
you know imagine having at any given
time day or night
having just some random person just one
it doesn't know
anything about our country or laws or
and they just
the only thing they know is that they
come here that
they get a bunch of free stuff and and
have them at any given time randomly
wander through your property
and not even give it a second thought
yeah and
uh you know you don't know who they are
why they're there
i mean if you in vermont if somebody
came and wandered through your yard
you'd be
hey what what are you doing what's up
what are you what are you doing here
you cannot understand what's really
truly going on
unless you come here and experience it
my head every night when i go to bed
it's very to explore
from the amount of information i've
taken in every day being here
talking to people 190 000 people have
been
have come through already um this in
this month
those are the ones that have been caught
they've been caught yes
and that and you know and then you've
got the drugs on top of that
and then there's a human trafficking one
which in and of itself is
just yeah you know tragic
you know if you want to come in this
country you are welcome but
come through the front door you know
yeah don't come here uninvited
come here legally like god bless him
roberto this gentleman who's been
working for me bill
pergola for me he's a legal citizen he
has his own construction company his son
works for him
yeah he makes money he has a house and
he's done really really well he's been
doing that here for 14 years
everybody loves roberto here he's great
great guy and i have all the
respect in the world for um you know
those people that want to come here and
do it legally
yeah just do it the right way i mean i i
you know
what's failing us is policies that are
making illegal acts somewhat legal yeah
and that's what we're not about as a
country that's not what we're about like
i've
lived in ukraine i've traveled many
parts of the world the beauty of coming
back to the states is like
the laws work for the most part there's
all sorts of corruption here too
but yeah look the system works yeah and
when you
when you start chipping at that the
influx of people was
was down a fraction of what it was what
it is now
and how it spiked so quickly i mean it
was just overnight it's just as soon as
biden went into office
this thing just exploded it's like those
black friday videos the doors closed and
then it opens black friday what do you
expect
yeah like i don't blame anyone for doing
it to be honest personally i don't yeah
because i would do the same thing if you
had to feed your family
i would do that you know what i mean
this is the people building the border
wall this facility
here but they're not building right now
right now they're actually on hold
southwest valley contractor
constructors
[Music]
the company is not screwed the company
has already been
paid to build that border wall so if the
gover the current government or
current administration decides not to
build that wall
never even paid how are the how are they
paid first
i have no idea how exactly that
government contract works
but like i said they've already been
paid so whether they want them to
build it they wanted to tear it down
they wanted to because rumors they might
cut it in half to
five feet high so no matter what they
want
the contractor to do the contractor
could care less
because it's already been paid for so
they can care less what the government
decides to do with the wall
some efficient use of government funds
it's always wasteful spending somewhere
oh my god so that all those people there
all those trucks are there people
actually going to work right now
or what are they they're actually
they're they're they're they're checking
out doing something somewhere but the
thing is
they're not building the wall it's on
hold they're thinking about re
starting up again according to the biden
administration
but whether that was a smoke signal or
not who knows
none of these politicians give a no
at the end of the day right nope
they're using it as leverage yep
right oh okay guys thank you raul
without raul we would not be getting
into any of this so
i want to thank raul and i also want to
plug the organization he works for the
united
cajun navy they go to all sorts of
different
catastrophes hurricanes tornadoes
and you might be here but not yet
correct
correct okay all right guys another day
on the border
if you haven't seen the other videos
from the series i will leave a link
below
i'm trying to hit it from as many angles
as possible
and hopefully you got something out of
that all right
thanks for all until the next
that's one a gate right there right that
the right side belongs to mexico the
left side belongs to the united states
and
they're basically the ones that control
the flow of water
up and down the river